[MUSIC PLAYING]
SOPHIE BEIERS: Hi, my
name is Sophie Beiers.
Thank you for watching my video.
I'm super honored to be a
part of this conference.
I definitely wish that we
could all be in person.
But in the meantime,
welcome to my kitchen.
I am excited to talk to you
a little bit about my process
in creating data visualizations
and data driven stories
at the ACLU.
So just a little bit about me.
I'm a data journalist
at the ACLU
where I analyze data for
our lawyers' legal arguments
and visualize and
report on our data
for external advocacy purposes.
I'm only a few years into being
a part of the R Community.
So I'm really
excited to be here.
So to start, what is data
science and data journalism
more broadly at the ACLU?
Some of you might
know and remember
Brooke Madubuonwu,
who spoke at the 2019 RStudio
Conference about her
data work in helping
reunify children that were
separated from their families
while seeking refuge
in our country.
She happens to be my awesome
manager and colleague.
And I felt she recently
summed up our work in just one
Slack that reads, the
lawyer called our analysis
both deeply disturbing
and extremely helpful
which might just be the
slogan for our team.
This leads me to an
important word to define,
terribulous, which is
commonly used on our team
as a way of
expressing excitement
over being able to prove
usually terrible news
with quantitative evidence.
Our analysis of the data
that we receive often
uncovers disparities
that hold up in court
and help our lawyers win
their legal arguments.
But in all seriousness,
what this often means
is the data that we are
privileged to analyze represent
real human beings who are being
harmed in one way or another.
I'll briefly share
with you a few examples
of what this might mean.
For example, each
row in this data
was a person that was
filed for eviction.
We found in this case
that filings for eviction
impacted black women at
alarmingly disproportionate
rates.
Another example is
this recent report
that we put out where we
found that black people,
despite using marijuana at the
same rates as white people,
are still being
disproportionately arrested
for possession of marijuana.
We also found that
people of color
were more likely to have their
driver's licenses suspended
due to unpaid and often
unaffordable fines and fees.
And we were able to visualize
the story of two black women
whose lives were turned upside
down without the ability
to use their cars.
All in all, I've been
really lucky to be
a part of these and other
data journalistic projects
during my time at the ACLU.
So I wanted to talk to you a
little bit about the process
that I often go
through and the key
steps I take in creating
my data visualizations.
This will include the
feedback that I sometimes
receive, what I've done or
not done with that feedback,
and other considerations
that I think
are important in getting
to a final result.
So some of you might be thinking
that it's just this easy.
You go from data analysis
to visualization.
You're good.
You have a great viz.
And you can go on and
just enjoy your weekend.
Maybe even I thought that at
one point based on this Slack
evidence when I
was analyzing data
few months into the pandemic
and came to the conclusion
that actually letting
incarcerated people out
of jails had no effect on
the crime levels nearby.
Spoiler, this is
not the process,
but it was the finding.
The actual process
in my experience
can be really messy and
definitely not linear.
But I'll share with you the
key elements and considerations
to take that I believe
have set me up for success
for projects like this.
First, you'll get some data.
A lot of the time
for us here that
means that a lawyer will
have some kind of data
that they've obtained
through the discovery process
or through a FOIA request.
And a lot of times we'll just
use publicly available data.
Next, you'll use R to read
and explore that data.
During the
exploration process, I
use the Tidyverse
quite a bit.
But also the janitor package
is one of my favorites
to make easy tables, and always
ggplot2 to find quick trends
and actually start
visualizing my findings.
So this is important.
By now, you'll want
to start thinking
about what are your
main points that you
found in your
exploration that you want
to visualize and make clear.
Ask yourself, does my
visualization support
and highlight my main point?
You'll also want to carefully
consider your audience.
Is your audience made
of purely academics?
Are they advocates?
Are they people who know a
lot about your topic already
or maybe they know
nothing at all?
It's always also good to ask for
feedback on your visualizations
from various people.
You'll want to be specific
about the main points
that you're trying to visualize
before receiving feedback
about whether those main points
are coming through clearly
or not to those people.
And then you might find that,
once you receive feedback,
you'll start iterating
on your data viz, which
means you'll likely need
to go back and forth
and check a lot of
these boxes again.
The process could end up
looking a lot like this.
Now, to show you how
I've gone about using
this process in practice,
I'll go through these steps
once more with a
real-life example.
For the purposes of the
example that I'll use,
I'll need to start with a
little bit of background
on this recent project
that our team worked on.
Sometime into the very beginning
of the COVID-19 pandemic,
it became really clear that
people in jails and people
that were incarcerated in
America, which by the way,
has the highest incarceration
rate in the world,
in particular would be at risk.
Incarcerated people are subject
to extreme overcrowding.
And jails often lack the
resources and facilities
that allow for handwashing
and other hygienic practices
that are necessary to slow
the spread of COVID-19.
So it was really clear that
in order to save lives,
action had to be taken.
And it had to be taken quickly.
Our team partnered with
academic researchers
to build a model that accounted
for the dynamics of the jail
system and estimated
the additional illnesses
and loss of life
that we'd expect
if none of these preventative
measures were taken.
We recommended
reducing arrests such
that people were
only being arrested
for the most serious
incidents and promptly
releasing people who were
pre-trial, or charged
for low-level crimes, or
were particularly vulnerable
to the disease and posed no risk
of immediate threat to others.
All in all, the team estimated
that taking these precautions
could save 100,000 human
lives both inside the jails
and in their
surrounding communities.
Many communities did
begin prioritizing
the lives of incarcerated
people and the people who
worked within jails.
And some localities
reduced low level arrests,
or set bond at zero,
or released a subset
of incarcerated people.
But there was some backlash.
Some people were worried
that taking these actions
would result in a
huge spike in crime
in the surrounding communities.
Despite research showing that,
in New York City for instance,
people released from
jails due to COVID
were rearrested at lower
rates than even expected.
To quell these concerns
further, our team
analyzed trends
in reported crimes
during the initial three
months of the pandemic
in 29 of the largest
US cities where
data was available and released
this report with our findings.
For the purposes
of this project,
our goal was to
find whether there
was any relationship between
the change in county jail
populations and the reported
crime rate in the closest
metropolitan area.
So back to the process,
starting with the data step,
we needed two categories of
data, one for county jail
populations and one that showed
the number of crimes reported
in the nearest city.
These were, ultimately, the
29 locations for which I could
find quality reported
crime data for,
for the time periods necessary
that were either aggregated
daily, weekly, or monthly for
all of 2019 through May 2020
that we could also find jail
population information for.
So we needed both.
We collected this data
a bit in piecemeal,
mainly through googling for
specific county sheriff's
offices or finding
public open data sets.
We ended up downloading
countless CSVs and Excel
files and even PDFs
continuously whenever
we noticed a new bit
of data had dropped,
hence the circular arrow
around the data step.
We also use the Vera
Institute's data
that tracked the number of
people in each county jail
over time.
And we ended up using the
specific dates of February 29
and April 30 to
calculate the percent
change in jail population.
Because most jails took action
early on in the pandemic,
we looked at the crime rates
during the time period of March
through May 2019 and compared
those to the same time
period in 2020.
And then to standardize the
way that we analyzed crime,
and also because many of these
cities' crime data sets only
included these
types of crimes, we
focused on part one crimes
which are defined by the Uniform
Crime Reporting Program.
And they encompass the most
frequently reported violent
and property crimes.
You'll see that data exploration
here was super messy for me.
This is an example of what
I saw using this function
from my very favorite
janitor package
on the crime description
column in just one city.
During my exploration,
I created this plot in R
which showed the relationship
between the magnitude
of the change in jail
population and the magnitude
of the change in crime
during that same time frame.
Now, it could be really tempting
to draw a regression line
and to try and focus on some
type of significant correlation
that just isn't there.
I received feedback
from my colleagues
that this graph focused
a little bit too much
on the outliers which were
one location that increased
their jail population
and one location where
there was more reported crime
than in the previous year.
It was then I realized
that one of the most
important main points
that I could make
was actually the lack of
relationship between x and y.
So after lots of data cleaning
and trying out more charts
and receiving more
feedback, these
were the three
main points that I
wanted to make
clear in my report
and visualize to my audience.
That, one, crime was not on the
rise compared to the same time
period the year prior.
Crime rates were instead
right within normal range
or even lower.
Second, most of the locales
that we found data for
did decrease their
jail populations
during this time period.
And like I said before,
just one location actually
increased its population.
Lastly and importantly,
we found no relationship
between the county jail
population and its increase
or decrease and the number
of crimes that were reported.
So once I decided on
these main points,
it was time to come up with
a few mockups of graphs
that I thought would
clearly express these.
Of course, though, this
is not always easy,
especially when you
realize that you
need to take your audience
into consideration.
So unfortunately,
this is an example
of a time where I
thought I nailed it.
I had come to the
perfect solution.
But I hadn't yet
considered our audience.
So this is a graph
that shows the 29
locations in order
of the percent
change in jail population.
The gray bar indicates the
range of monthly crimes
between January 2018
and February 2020.
And the three dots indicate
the number of monthly crimes
reported in March,
April, and May of 2020.
You'll see that a lot
of the time the three
dots are to the
left of the gray bar
but never are they to
the right of the gray bar
which indicates
that reported crime
during these first few
months of the pandemic
were within normal or
expected range or lower.
I will give credit to Lucia,
or chief analytics officer,
for scribbling down this
idea, in Slack, of course,
but will give credit
to myself for what
I thought was kind of
incredible execution.
The team of data scientists,
of course, loved it.
I thought I was basically done.
But let's remember,
your audience is key.
So the next day I received
the following feedback
from several
non-analytics folks.
It honestly was a
little bit like reading
my own bad reviews.
But it's important not to
look at constructive feedback
that way.
These colleagues were speaking
up about some major issues
with this graph.
You might agree.
I agree now.
They were right.
I see feedback that's qualified
with things like, I'm not
a numbers person, a lot.
People sometimes
blame themselves
for not knowing how to
interpret a data viz.
But it's actually really
our job to make sure
that the viz works for them
and works for our audience.
So this crimes and
decarceration report
was not just for
data scientists.
It was for a far more
general audience.
And this chart was
clearly not working.
So sometimes this means going
back to the drawing board,
doing a little bit
more data exploration,
always with the janitor
and ggplot packages for me,
and trying out new
ways of visualizing
your main points while
thinking about your audience.
These charts where
hashtag innoventive,
but they simply weren't working.
Some of the most valuable
feedback conversations I had
were not over Slack.
So I have no hard evidence.
But in the times that
you're asking for feedback
from someone, it's
really important
to ask the why behind something
isn't working for them.
Sometimes the why might
be sort of surprising,
or maybe it'll make
you actually realize
that what you need to do is
add better annotating rather
than just scrapping the whole
thing and starting over.
And in the spirit of reiterating
that this process was one messy
adventure, before showing you
the final visualizations we
ended up with, at
the end of the day,
I really feel like this quote
just drives it all home.
So these were the final graphics
that we published on our site.
Both were created in R and
touched up in Illustrator.
Both, I feel, do a good
job of expressing our three
main points and are not just
interpretable for quote,
"numbers people."
I know these are probably
a little bit hard to see.
So I'll share a link to my
report in my presentation
as well as where you can find
the R code for the analysis
and viz.
And one last wrench
I'll throw at you,
because it was thrown at
me, was that it turns out
police data is often dynamic,
meaning that sometimes crimes
that occurred
actually maybe a month
ago could have been
reported today.
I cannot stress enough how much
of a life saver reusable code
in R was throughout this process
given the amount of extremely
last-minute data dumps and the
changing out the CSV files here
and there.
We wanted to be precise.
And thanks to R, that remaking
these graphs time and time
again was such a small deal.
So hopefully,
through this process,
I've been able to convince
you that data viz is
and should often be non-linear.
Mentors in my life
have taught me
that being good at making
effective visualizations
is not about getting from point
A to point B the quickest.
It's actually about
carefully considering
each of these points that makes
you an effective communicator
to your audience.
Lastly, feel free to reach out
to me if you have any questions
or just want to nerd out
about data viz, and thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]